bella tutti ragazzi benvenuti avesse un
video sono parigino e ci siamo su wii
chip che questo gioco veramente
bellissimo dove tutti i piedi
trasformare in un oggetto e sfuggire
agli avversari ci trasformi proprio in
un oggetto e devi nasconderti e gli
altri ti passano vicino e non sanno che
tutti devono trovare veramente
fighissimo sta giocando mister vedere
però il mio mi piace l'ex coop
raga mi ricordo che ci giochiamo
dobbiamo giocare qualcosa facciamo chi
mi gioco il mio cane e il gatto vostro
cane per cane cane perché il cane non ci
piace il gatto e trasparenti
mamma mia ragazzi come siamo messi una
rischia via su finito di sistemare
ancora caldi lo vedo lo vedo coro ed ora
però ho visto usando come posso previsto
proprio il non ci credo non ci credo
eccolo dai atto iii che pirla la mafia
una gallina che stai no che c'è un buco
da oscar bambini qua allora un sorriso
non prenderti capirla
eccoti aiuto vieni qua smettila vi prego
lasciamo in pace ma è difficile
prenderti lo stesso no non voglio
abbastanza male di per sé è l'unica
strada rimasta gol e io mi sono nascosta
primo pit stop ho avuto un occhio di
falco ma è stato incredibile è stato
subito l'emirato azzurri da devo sparare
gallina marchese mahler è possibile
poi io che non c'è solo gradi al nord
lancera che butta vieni prossima e
ubriaco mammamia orribile ma c'è tutto
sta zona sotto fatto sì mi sa di sì
porco demonio persa mamma mia che sfiga
come ho fatto a farmi divulgare la
faccia ma date una bella mossa però
stupido ma non sapevo neanche si potesse
fare impresa tutta comoda suggerimento
dato che mancano trenta secondi è un
pochino più in basso di dove sei
[Musica]
infatti la finira lo zio era mai trovata
mai
dovevo fidanzato 920 oggetti ho guardato
ci ha pensato mamma mia ragazza
bellissima io questo gioco veramente non
so cosa ci ama e lo amo bellissima devo
già studiare dalle nascondermi diciamo è
qualche idea non è ora il sì mezzo il
posto enorme pieno di nascondigli quindi
avete l'imbarazzo della scelta
[Musica]
io come scatta il timer part ok ok di
successo è la maniera dalla sede aperta
fortuna e la situazione è terribile 10
26 si usi questo se lo hanno scoperto e
dire no non è lavori dell'aula del
vostro aiuto ma noi non farà più forti è
cambiata oggi aiuto ma cosa sto bene
ma dai io prendo
non è possibile che ansia aver preso il
peggiore se il file con la prima zona
che si controlla scusa ma volevo fare
proprio perché è bello sto nascondigli
piace a rischio di si è un po pericoloso
è poi però penso che non si troverà mai
addirittura se fosse così non dire
niente ma pinton e non ti vedo molto
bene il profilo giusto sassanelli ha
fatto una magia strana cosa
scompare ma vaaaa esatto se per il
trasportato via per ma non so come
guarda di nuovo se continua a scappare
ea genere spiega mirato idea adesso non
lo so perché cambia finché poi erano al
meglio vede quando faccio questo
transfer mendes si vede una lucina
aprendo interesso dai denti e non
capisci riferito di robin un oggetto
vicino quindi se ti colpisce in oggetto
e poi io vado su quell'oggetto che già
colpito tu non pensi mai che io sono
dell'oggetto quando eri lì fair e io
adesso sede trasportato via ma in realtà
era in quella stanza
sì ma io e rimandato una gallina voglio
non c'è più e perché ormai è nato via
besta
non so come funziona la politica questa
che diamo però da scappato di nuovo
metterò patente sto potere attenzione 6
secondi 5
è forse questo è troppo piccolo e molto
mi è veramente troppo strano provo
appena eletto detto il mio subito una
raffica di patate escluso come volte
beccarla subita è vero storto con lo
schifo hai avevi scappare veramente
storta
eros cortissimo posizione devo dargli un
dettaglio di questa mappa dato che si
parte dalla gabbia che cell in cielo se
guardate sopra tipo una cosa in legno ok
vedi tutto quindi attendere verso li
lago verranno trovate zone dove si vede
un coraggio dei pochi giganti
io ho provato ho messo non hanno potere
per il tipo che questo prevedere così se
ne va uno specifico ed islamica per
prendere tutti gli oggetti vicini
potrebbero quindi del diavolo è fallito
e rampe georgia di partenza io ai miei
sospetti e secondo me o ad un limite
esagerato in alto oppure sulla spiaggia
ok io faccio la nave perché prima non è
stata utilizzata e che mi sembra un buon
posto dove ti sei me è impossibile cioè
non ti sto veramente trovando la smetta
ha trovato la gallina alla gallina canta
attenzione a te comoda guarda qua la
galina sta cantando forse 18 può essere
ma sto controllando cavolo ma è
possibile che magie fa questa calma
[Musica]
trovata dov'è il cuscino e in colle
vicino a dove sei ogni torri bodysurf
pretoria e starò ma dove l'hai fatta
sparire
che è bello ma se ieri introvabile
ragazzi l'ultima mi cercate voi voglio
provare a fare ok va rifatta è pronto
quindi di particolare
[Musica]
io sto andando in giro stesse facendo la
nova stage ronzan nostra gironzolando
cercando cose strane perché lui è
qualcosa che comunque ha visto e ha
pensato cavolo sta roba geniale quindi
ovviamente cosa che vedo penso al cavolo
star ove geniale
c'è anche una seconda nave season due le
navi per questo possa ma non può essere
così banale è qualcosa di più è qualcosa
di speciale
è qualcosa che nessuno penserebbe però
io avendo problemi con stop panzone oplà
non è la più pallida idea ci sono tanti
posti che potenzialmente sono geniali e
che le rovine
ap non c'è nulla da vedere in questo
posto di particolare c'è chi dice oh
cavolo lo so io sono zitto perché non lo
so cosa dire milano linate fantastico
ragazzi allora questo angolino secondo
me non è banale come le navi e quindi
nella fu un po farinone bayern non è
banale ragazzi ma è ovvio è ovvio ma io
a trovare se una parte sono spalmando
galli non cambia niente insuccesso era
caduto
io quello che volevo realmente fare non
sono riuscito a farlo ti do questi
indizi incredibile quindi li voleva
andare in un certo punto non ha potuto
quindi un punto modelli che c'è la
barriera
non c'è la kia barriera no dai non è
possibile allora ragionamento che stai
facendo prima era giusto
niente del genere sono affari io stavo
controllando le varie buche che ci sono
della montagna per andare nei posti alpi
venete ho avuto un presentimento del
presidente era completamente giusto ma
non sono riuscito ad arrivare lì siamo
stati morto questo qual era il tuo
presentimento stampa ricorda più
[Musica]
ecco il bavero a tutti e due i lati
pollino per la roma ci avete vi siete
passati conta tantissimo davanti non è
della nave semplicemente volevo andare
sopra la vostra gabbia per salerno che
io pensavo a tutto il tempo esatto
solo che non sono riuscito perché è
veramente troppo in alto
ragazzi spero che mi sia piaciuto
ringrazio state fair e passate la locale
ingiustizia e fateci sapere se volete
altri video di we ci preme era figata
incredibile non sono iscritti al canale
è piaciuto la campanella e noi ci
vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]